[Music]
let's get to the budget
the uh the giveaway chancellor was still
giving away in this week's budget but
there was a
later sting in the tale a huge rise in
taxes from 2023 onwards to help
pay for all this spending and to restore
some order
to the public finances in terms of the
annual borrowing
amount and the overall national debt
which is now in
uh the trillions let's go uh to get a
briefing from our economics
correspondent kate andrews
thanks andrew this week the chancellor
presented his second
budget to the house rishi sunak at this
point is uh no stranger to splashing the
cash
and this was no exception we got 65
billion pounds
of additional spending a lot of that's
going to go on immediate covert relief
extending the furlough scheme till
september
extending that uplift to universal
credit business grants and much more
but in addition to the giveaways we also
got some tough pills to swallow in the
form of tax hikes
corporation tax is going up to 25
uh for big business by 2023 and there's
also been
a freeze to personal tax thresholds i'm
sure we're going to discuss that
after the slideshow but i want to look
at the office for budget responsibility
and what they published alongside
the budget because we got some updated
forecasts that gives us some insight
as to where we think the economy is
headed
and what we can make from that so as you
can see from this first slide the obr
have brought forward
their projection of reaching
pre-pandemic levels of gdp
uh to q2 next year it's not that much of
a change it was expected to be
q3 but it is something um here you can
see that big contraction of 9.9
for 2020 this year we're expected to
grow by 4
next year really quite amazing 7 and
then returning to business as usual
after that with an average of
roughly 1.6 growth now the reason
that that percent is there for this year
reflects the fact that we're going to be
in a
very strict lockdown in winter and
hopefully be open and having a booming
economy
in the summer and data from the oecd
which has been analyzed by the spectator
has found that despite low levels of
covid in the uk compared to our european
counterparts the uk is not only one of
the most locked down countries
but it's also suffering from some of the
slowest gdp growth per week if you
compare
our gdp to last year now what this slide
is is really showing is that quite
obviously the more locked down you are
the harder it is
to bounce back and and that means that
we're not going to have the same level
of growth
this year that we may potentially have
next year
but moving on um to other news from the
obr
really good news actually if we look at
unemployment originally the obr had
forecast 11.9 percent
to be the peak of unemployment and
that's fallen right down to 6.5 percent
this really boosts the credibility
of the furlough scheme and perhaps
explains why it's being extended
until september with hopes that with the
economy very open this summer conditions
will be better
for those furloughed workers many of
whom may discover their job doesn't
exist anymore
will be able to come into a jobs market
that is perhaps a bit
more active but none of this has been
cheap and as you can see here the debt
is now estimated to be at
2.8 trillion pounds if deficit
projections are anything to go by it's
going to keep going up by quite a lot
public spending was up by a quarter in a
year
last year 355 billion pounds borrowed in
2020 2021.
it's forecast for 2021-22 that's going
to be
234 billion pounds you can no longer say
that the cover crisis is a one-off
spending spree
by the time we get to 2024 2025 we're
still borrowing
estimated to be borrowing over a hundred
billion pounds
a year now some people will say that's
really not a problem because
look here at this slide how cheap it is
to service that
debt but there are still several issues
here it's not just about the amount of
debt but the ratio of jet
of debt to gdp that really matters which
is now hovering just below 100 percent
and second and perhaps this is the most
important slide actually to explain
this budget it's just how vulnerable we
are when it comes to servicing
that debt and that's what we're looking
at in this week's magazine the fear that
was playing on the chancellor's mind
when he decided to hike taxes and
present the budget that he did
because while conditions for borrowing
are extremely agreeable right now
if there's even the slightest bit of
movement historically low movement
as you can see here one percentage point
change in
interest rates guilt rates or in
inflation then we could be looking at a
25 billion pound
black hole that the chancellor would
have to fill
that's roughly finding the school's
budget if it's a two percentage point
increase that's finding the defense
budget um and that could prove extremely
painful for the country
and very politically difficult for the
conservative party having to come up
with that money
in such a short period of time and so
it's it's this concern i think that has
really
driven what you saw in the budget this
week
which we can discuss now so back over to
you andrew okay
uh kate thank you for that it's
fascinating
charts i'm going to come back to the
economics of the budget in a minute but
let me come to our political level james
forsyth and some of the
the politics of this james is there now
talking westminster because
he's talking about you know no tax
increases for a while
but then from 2023 onwards there's quite
substantial increases both in
corporation tax and in household on
income tax
as well because the thresholds are going
to be frozen almost every threshold
is actually being frozen are we thinking
of a 2023 election now
i i don't mean there is a firm date in
the government's mind when they want to
have the election but i think when you
heard the chance to read out the growth
forecast talking about you know seven
percent growth plus
in 2022 then 1.7 in 2023 and then
1.6 1.5 you would you would it would be
you would
surely want to have the election as
close to that 7
that year of 7 growth of a feel-good
factor
rather than have it after a couple of
years of 1.6
you know fairly anemic growth you know
solid but not spectacular
i also think the other the other
calculation that has shifted
is i think uh six months ago when the
government's handling of the pandemic
was being
widely panned public confidence was low
you would think the government would
want to hold the election as far away
from covert as possible
but as your discussion uh david
spiegelhofer showed
you know that there is there is
something the government is now getting
right the vaccine roll out
and the uk might be able to get rid of
restrictions quicker than other european
countries get life back to normal
and so again you might have a kind of
kind of a kind of halo effect from that
that you would want to tap into in an
election campaign
and of course before the fixed term
parliament act which
sort of mandated except in special
circumstances
uh a five-year parliament four years i
think james was about the norm for most
parliaments wasn't it
yeah i mean the issue here is that this
would be three and a half years
essentially because i don't think anyone
wants to go to
the polls in the winter again as has
happened at the last election
so you would probably be talking about a
kind of classic may
2023 kind of date um but but you are
right you know normally
parliament's only went the full five
years if a government was in trouble
think of john major in 1997 you know
you you clung on desperately in the hope
that something would turn up
but normally you look at margaret
thatcher government successful
governments like
tony blair successful governments like
to go after four years
fraser our editor of the spectator i i
listen to the chancellor on the
today program on radio 4 this morning
and i thought he came really unstuck
over corporation tax
i mean to see what your take is on this
i mean
for 10 years when i interviewed tories
about the cost of the corporation tax
cuts they all said but they'll pay for
themselves you know there'll be a sort
of laffer curve effect
and we'll end up with more revenue
now that your chancellor is telling us
that if he ups
corporation tax um he'll take in more
revenue
than he would otherwise i mean both
statements can't be right can they
well we're certainly stretching the
elastic of what used to be uh
tory economics and i mean the the people
you were talking to andrew were actually
quite correct
and corporation tax did keep going down
but the revenue kept going up
now might it have gone up even higher
there are higher rates
the thing is that corporation tax was a
little bit of
a misleading indicator because the
actual burden of tax the companies face
has got a lot to do with the deductions
of what they can count off against tax
so what george osborne was quite good at
doing was lowering the headline rate of
corporation tax but
also taking away the deductions so
companies pretty much ended up paying
the same there's a very interesting part
in the obr documents
and where they show exactly the ruse
here
the rate went down but the outdoor
burden stayed high so in a way
the the the great giveaway was never
quite as generous
as it seemed now you could argue rishi
sunik's coming along saying look i'm
going to increase
the allowances i'm going to let you
write off 130 percent
of the value of machinery that you might
buy against tax
and isn't that generous that raises the
prospect of a kind of reversal of the
osborne years the
allowance is getting more generous even
though the rate is going up
but when you look at the obr's
calculations it shows you but the rate
is going up
way way faster than the allowances this
is going to be
the biggest increase in corporation tax
since since dennis healey
in 1974 and we're going to end up
with the with one of europe's heaviest
corporation taxers now what you can't i
mean
richie sonic was asked on the radio this
morning what have you stopped believing
that if you lower the tax rates the
yields
might go up that was a bit of a trick
question because
somebody who is a supply side or in the
tory party would
say that's only the case for certain
circumstances the top rate of tax for
example you could lower that
and the rate would probably go up but
then again it's probably marginal
but the truth which russia wouldn't
admit is that
corporation tax is one of the only taxes
he's got to play with
the manifesto stops him increasing
income tax
and the prime minister stops them
curtailing the spending because number
10
is a very spent happy administration
plural rishi sunak is his job
to somehow finance the spending being
authorized in number 10
but do it being banned from touching
most taxes apart from corporation tax
i suspect it won't raise nearly as much
money as he thinks
but unfortunately it's the only tool he
really has to play with
kate i was fascinated by your cover
story this week of the spectator and the
specter of inflection
because it is it has been the kind of uh
hovering in the background we've been in
this incredibly
benign atmosphere for so long that
governments can borrow at the lowest
possible interest rates the
cost of servicing the debt no i mean
the size of our national debt at the
moment is at wartime levels but the cost
of
servicing the debt is a lot lower than
it was when our national debt was a lot
smaller
but that all changes if inflation was
was to come back and that would make the
bond markets
nervous and it would make fisk fiscal
positions
far less sustainable and i was
interested that you you think the
chancellor is worried about this
absolutely there's been a lot of talk
leading up to the budget that the
chancellor might be raising taxes to
pay down the debt i don't think the
chancellor at the moment has such
lofty dreams this is about a much more
immediate concern
and that is that these conditions for
borrowing that are so agreeable at the
moment
only need to change just slightly for
him to be in a really difficult
position and weeks ago frankly the
economic consensus
seemed to be that everything was going
to be fine it would be rude not to
borrow this money
it's so cheap it's so cheap to service
the debt but something has started to
change now you don't have major
economists coming out and predicting
inflation but you have very senior
people like larry summers who is by no
means
a fiscal hawk he was treasury secretary
under bill clinton economic guru to
barack obama
in the united states he's looking at joe
biden's 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package
which is going to land just as the
economy is booming open because the u.s
is
having a big vaccine success story at
the moment and he's saying this is
extremely risky we
may well be risking inflation and over
here you have the
chief economist of the bank of england
andy haldane releasing a speech last
week all on this topic again
not going so far as to predict it but he
concludes by saying this is a real
possibility we are very vulnerable
we just don't know what happens when you
artificially suppress an economy
and then open the doors again we don't
have a playbook for this
so credible people are talking about it
and it's certainly weighing on the
chancellor's mind he wants to make sure
that if interest rates guilt yields
inflation
budge ever so slightly he's going to be
able to find as i showed in that graph
25 billion pounds potentially more
in order to cover it james
there have been movements in the bond
markets in recent days that corroborate
what kate
is saying but this if if this is now a
concern this goes
way beyond the british government i mean
this place to the heart
of the debt dynamics of the eurozone i
mean if you look at
uh france could now be heading towards a
a
debt to gdp ratio of about 120
i think italy is already over 140 and
rising portugal's
not far behind spain is enormous as well
all that debt has been financed either
through european central bank
qe or being done by the governments
themselves because interest rates are so
low
and they've been able to get that debtor
away if what kate is saying is now
coming on to the
policy agenda that's a real problem for
the eurozone
yeah and i mean there are two two other
factors worth considering here one is
but the qe that followed the financial
crisis essentially went
into repairing banks balance sheets so
it didn't really go into the real
economy
the qe that has happened during this
crisis has gone into consumers pockets
and also if you look at the amount of
savings that have been built up in this
country during the pandemic
you can quite easily see how when people
come out
you know that there's a rush for home
improvements and the like and that
creates an
inflationary pressure then you add to
that as kate says you know
the us has the global reserve currency
so so it has far
more room for maneuver but it could be
you look at the size of this binding
stimulus and it could be about to inject
quite a sizable bit of inflation into
the world system i think you saw
the bank of japan getting nervous about
this you know this is going to be a big
issue and as you say
you know the eurozone you know it's it
i always think it's about the eurozone
we've stopped talking about
the euro because but its problems are
still there it's simply just in an acute
state
rather in a chronic state rather than an
acute state if
interest rates start rising you know it
could get back
into the acute state date really quite
fast
fraser you know over the years as we've
done our budget
uh uh shows in the aftermath and so on
we've
talked about uh how the government
from 2010 onwards was trying to get the
annual deficit down
bit by bit as a percentage of gdp was it
succeeding or
not and whatever it did of course
national debt uh continued to rise
of course all these figures we used to
be talking about an annual deficit of
about
you know 40 45 billion pounds i think
the one this year
is going to be over 300 billion
in your view given that the chancellor
does seem to be aware of the concerns
that kate was raising
is britain's fiscal position
as sustainable as it can be in the
current climate
it's difficult to say really i mean
could we have got away could we have got
through this crisis
with less debt i think the answer is
certainly we could have done if you look
at
the deficit that we had during 2020 the
uk was one of the worst hit countries
economically and that is linked to the
stringency
of lockdown not only was our economy hit
the worst but our debt went
up the most and the funny thing is
though that i think this budget was
written
not yesterday in the treasury but it was
written
when the government decided to extend
the most stringent lockdown in the world
as it currently is
for as long as they have done when you
extend furlough scheme
until september long after reopening is
supposed to be
going on when you start to answer every
single problem with a massive
tax massive spending splurge then you
start to create the biggest tax burden
in 50 years and that's what we've ended
up with
i think what russia sunnac is doing is
holding up a mirror
to the prime minister here saying look
this is the bill for everything that
you've promised
this is the bill for the toughest
lockdown in the world and every week it
continues
it simply gets more expensive and
somebody's going to have to pay
for that money so i think that we could
have got through this crisis without
doing um as much fiscal damage as we did
but it's a bit too late now for that the
prime minister has tied himself to his
uh dates not data schedule of of moving
out
of lockdown and the bank of england has
also printed as much money as the
government has borrowed
so what we really don't know is what the
markets are going to think
of the continued hunger for deficit
spending after the bank of england stops
printing so we're about as stable as any
other european country right now which
is to say not very
no really no country really knows how
it's going to be until
first of all the quantitative easing
stops secondly the economies rebound and
we can see how strong
that is and thirdly we wait for the
fallback from
joe biden's massive spending splurge
which could
trigger the inflationary wave he pours
lots of vodka
on the post-pandemic party that america
is about to have with a bailout which is
something like four times the size
of a stimulus that obama did after the
crash
so we've got a lot of question marks and
a lot of questions that will be answered
by the end of this year and kate that is
a concern in london isn't it the size of
the biden stimulus
almost 2 trillion on top of what trump
had done and other spending
as well and as you look at some of the
supply side constraints already visible
in america
even labor in some constraint too uh
housing things you need to build houses
and all the rest of it
uh that's people are having trouble
sourcing quite a lot supply chains
already coming under pressure
there's a fear as i understand that that
if
inflation kicks off in america as a
result of this
that makes the danger all the worse for
britain oh certainly what happens in
america is going to affect the rest of
the world and as
andy haldane laid out in his speech last
week he says
um that what kept inflation so low for
so long those conditions have
fundamentally
changed we're not going to have another
china come on to the world market
for example and as you say andrew
globalization's taken a real hit
we just don't know how quickly it'll
come back if it's going to limp or
if it's going to if it's going to roar
back now before the budget
you had people saying rishi sunak is
going to use joe biden as cover
to to hike corporation tax to do these
big state things
because the president's doing it as well
and in the magazine this week
i note that a a senior tory source says
that's not quite the case in fact it's
it's very very different from that rishi
sunak's not trying to be joe biden he's
trying to protect
from what joe biden might do to the uk
economy
and because as friedrich hayek once
famously noted
inflation is like a tiger and you're
trying to chase it by its tail once the
cat's out of the bag it's
it's near impossible to catch so if
things start to move they can start to
move really quickly
and now the key is that nothing may
change and that would be hard for the
chancellor if if his fears that he's
planning for
they don't become a reality people will
say well you were yet again
overly cautious you were too prudent
this was unnecessary pain
but if something were to change the
chancellor would be the person who
prepared for it
who planned for it and who tried to make
the uk slightly more resilient
to what might be happening in the states
or elsewhere
james let me come to you for a final
question this segment
my understanding is that the despite the
tax rises and all the rest of it that
the tory backbenchers are not in a
revolting mood
by and large they're either accepting it
or they're killing the
lips button for the moment but
if the election is to come in 2023
given the importance of the red wall
uh the seats that they won in 2019 old
labor seats that
some seats they had won for a generation
if ever
and they've got this leveling up agenda
as well with some money being spent
are they really going to be in a
position as they go around the red wall
constituencies by 2023
to say look at this improvement we've
done here look how this town center
is booming here look how we've cleared
these slams we've built
a new clinic you know all the things
will there really be visible signs like
that that they can say
this is a real improvement compared to
2019
i mean this is one of the big challenges
to them you know i think that
lots of voters in these red wall seats
take their state of their local high
street as a proxy
for is where they live better off than
it was four years ago
i think one of the problems is covet has
accelerated
all of the changes hitting the high
street you know the shift from
from from bricks and mortar retail to
online for instance
so i think they are going to have to do
kind of big planning reform to make the
high street more residential
things like that i also think though
that the public will accept
that you know the government have lost a
whole bunch of time to covet i think one
of the challenges for
labor is you know that they i think they
thought that they would be able to say
quite definitively at the next election
the tories have been in power for 14
years and once you've been in power for
14 years
essentially everything is your fault but
you know i mean how much longer do you
need to fix it
i think now the political argument will
be slightly different the government
will be talking about being two years
into its coveted recovery plan
you know there's this build back better
slogan so
i i think voters will get that you know
there has been an interruption
uh but i think as you say the particular
problem i think is that in these places
people will say well you know my local
high street and and that
that high streets have undoubtedly been
one of the things that hit
hardest by covert
[Music]
you